[Musica]
[Applauso]
funziona forza il microfono e ora
partiamo preferireste
coltivare un futuro
costruito
sull'individualità o sulla socialità
ognuno di voi dovrebbe essere libero di
scegliere per se stesso perché ognuno di
voi conosce perfettamente
quali sono le esperienze di vita che
volete che desiderate vivere e quelle
che volete evitare
penso capiti anche a voi di fermarli ad
osservare le vostre giornate ed
accorgersi di essere bombardati da
un'infinità di informazioni stimoli
notizie trovarvi con così tanti impegni
da non riuscire ad avere il tempo di
respirare essere in ansia per la
consegna di un progetto
preoccupati perché avete un appuntamento
importante ma dovete attraversare la
città e c'è l'ora di punta del traffico
tutti aspetti e stimoli che durante una
giornata spesso si sommano e il nostro
autocontrollo va in tilt
in questi momenti è normale
desiderare un po di calma prendere
distanza da tutto e da tutti
cercare di trovare il tempo di per
rimanere da soli è normale ma
attenzione
questo è anche il momento in cui
inizi a coltivare dei semi di
individualità
voglio farvi una domanda
secondo voi se io nel mio terreno della
vita pianto semi di individualità
cosa pensate che raccolgo quando daranno
i loro frutti
raccoglierò solitudine
io oggi sono qui e vi parlo di cohousing
che tradotto significa coabitare insieme
alcuni di voi vorrebbero dirmi cosa io
abitare con altre persone in casa no
altri esperienza già fatta quando
studiavo fuori e condivideva
l'appartamento con altri studenti
voglio fare chiarezza il cohousing non è
la casa del grande fratello dove tutti
condividono gli stessi spazi
nello stesso momento né tantomeno quel
contratto d'affitto che hai firmato per
la camera con uso di cucina bagno e
lavanderia il cohousing
e l'opportunità di adottare è di
tramandare
un modello di abitare all'insegna della
sostenibilità una sostenibilità dove gli
spazi condivisi e gli spazi privati si
fondono insieme
per dare vita a una sostenibilità che
guarda oltre i benefici dell'ambiente
una sostenibilità che fa riscoprire il
valore delle condivisioni
e delle relazioni
dove grazie a un'economia circolare
risparmi tempo e denaro
questo non è un modello di ultima
generazione fa parte di noi da sempre i
primi esseri umani lo hanno adottato per
necessità di sopravvivenza in tante aree
del nostro pianeta fa parte della loro
cultura
per noi oggi
l'opportunità
di poter scegliere consapevolmente tra i
tanti modelli che si stanno diffondendo
in tutto il mondo
voglio condividere con voi alcuni dati
negli stati uniti sono già 100 mila le
persone che hanno scelto questo modello
nel nord europa dove il primo gruppo si
è formato negli anni sessanta sono già
più cinquemila anche in italia stiamo
crescendo si stima che siamo intorno ai
1000 mille persone
per lo più nel centro italia ma si
stanno veramente modelli diffondendo in
tutta le nostre il nostro paese
la mia esperienza di cohousing
nasce nel
1964 anno in cui sono nata
certo c'è da dire che nascerà in quegli
anni in un piccolo borgo dell'umbria
dove si era immersa nella natura
meravigliosa ma anche dove gli abitanti
conoscevano tutto di tutti e quando vi
dico tutti conoscevano di tutto vi
assicuro era proprio così
mia mamma
quando ero bambina non si preoccupava
mai se mi allontanavo da sola per le vie
del borgo
tanto ci sarebbe stata un'altra mamma
una nonna una zia la vicina attenta
a capire con chi giocavo dove ero
entrata da quali persone mi ero fermato
a parlare se avevo parlato con uno
sconosciuto quanto mi ero allontanata da
dove abito e poi lo racconta la mamma
certo molti di voi ora potrebbero
pensare che ansia vivere così lo
immagino meno male che vivo da solo nel
mio appartamento nella mia casa e non
conosco nemmeno i miei vicini
posso essere d'accordo con voi
infatti
all'età di vent'anni eppure io ho
cercato di prendere distanza e liberarmi
da questa modalità infatti mi sono
sposata sono andata a vivere in città in
un'app in un appartamento all'interno di
una palazzina dove conoscevo solo alcune
famiglie
però poi
arrivato un giorno che ho fatto
un'esperienza abbastanza forte e
prolungata
che mi ha fatto a rivalutare il valore
che ha
abitare in un luogo dove tutti si
conoscono e si aiutano
sono stati i dieci anni in cui mio padre
gradualmente ha perso la sua memoria
in quel periodo ricordo che guardavo
mamma ed osservavo il suo disagio
ascoltavo il suo senso di vuoto
insieme ai miei fratelli
cercavamo di colmare quella sua
sensazione di solitudine
ma è stato grazie
a quell aiuto offerto gratuitamente
dagli abitanti del borgo che ho capito
l'importanza di una partecipazione
condivisa tra famiglia
poi è arrivato il giorno che i miei
genitori non ci sono più
e al loro capito che potevo fare
qualcosa
e ho iniziato a gettare le basi per un
modello
che potesse assomigliare a ciò che io
avevo fatto come esperienza
o meglio piantato semi veramente perché
le persone possano coltivare
quotidianamente
connessioni con la natura e con le
persone
vedete oggi siamo in un mondo internet
lo smartphone ci mette collegati un po
con tutti
pensiamo di avere una rete una rete
diffusa di
colleghi amici parenti conoscenti
quindi dici vabbè è impossibile che
resta sola basta avere un telefonino in
mano a tante persone a cui contattare
ma di recente tutti noi abbiamo fatto
un'esperienza che forse questo lo ha
fatto un attimino rivedere
ricordate cosa è successo durante il
periodo di lock down
cosa abbiamo capito abbiamo capito che
abbiamo bisogno di contatti
abbiamo la necessità fisica di un
abbraccio di salutare qualcuno
stringendogli la mano
dimostrare il nostro affetto attraverso
un bacio
abbiamo capito che sono le connessioni
virtuali non bastano
e allora molti di noi hanno iniziato a
parlare con il vicino accanto a
prendersi cura della signora che abitava
magari da sola
lì nel palazzo e aveva bisogno di fare
la spesa e allora chiedevamo se era una
necessità mentre andavamo a fare la
spesa per noi ci siamo uniti nella
catena di applausi da dedicare a ai
medici e agli infermieri che erano
impegnati a salvare vite umane abbiamo
cantato la stessa canzone
nello stesso momento in tutte le città
del paese pur di sentirci in un
abbraccio condiviso
sono nata immersa nella natura ho
conosciuto
il sapore ed il valore di mangiare ciò
che mio nonno produceva nell'orto in
base alle stagioni
motivo per cui non riesco ad immaginare
il mio modello senza del terreno da
dedicare ad una coltivazione
biologica e sinergica ci sono
un'infinità di ricerca che medico
scientifiche che portano in evidenza
l'importante di mangiare cibi sani per
nutrire la nostra salute
si promuove l'uso di alimenti a km zero
prediligere i frutti di stagione questo
perché perché se mangi in modo sano se
scegli cibi di stagione coltivate in
modo sano nutre il valore più importante
nutriamo tutti noi la nostra salute
sono stati tutti questi valori
e la lettura che dei
benefici vantaggi che avevo vissuto
quell'esperienza che avevo fatto ad
accendere in me queste intuizioni di
unire
l'agricoltura e il cohousing creando il
modello agricolo singh
un modello
che oggi permette di abitare luoghi
innanzitutto
riutilizzare il patrimonio edilizio
degli edifici rurali abbandonate ma è
anche un posto che consente di abbattere
i costi di abitare in
una casa singola
avere opportunità di un'occupazione di
lavoro
riuscire ad avere fine hanno un reddito
grazie alla condivisione degli spazi
condivisi
ma non solo è è un modello che consente
di abitare in un posto dove puoi contare
su valide persone che ti possono aiutare
nella gestione quotidiana di figli e
persone anziane
un luogo dove la connessione con la
natura e quelle persone si allena tutti
i giorni un posto in cui nutrire e
arricchire naturalmente le proprie
relazioni un luogo quanto meno questo è
il modello che sogno dove realmente i
sensi sono tutti attivati dove guardo
dove ascolto dove respiro dove tocco con
mano dove riuscire ad assaporare le
bontà di ogni stagione un luogo dove il
seme dell'individualità
naturalmente
si trasforma
in opportunità di vivere momenti ricchi
di colore e sapore
vi lascio e chiudo il mio intervento con
questo proverbio africano
se le formiche si mettono d'accordo
possono spostare un elefante
a me piace dire l'unione non fa solo la
forza
l'unione aiuta a fare la differenza
[Applauso]